en este vídeo vamos a establecer una
conexión entre el costo de oportunidad
de producir un bien en un país
determinado y la ventaja comparativa
entre países en determinado bien aquí
tenemos una gráfica que muestra las
curvas de posibilidades de producción de
dos países distintos es un modelo muy
simplificado pero nos va a ayudar a
obtener algunas ideas en cada país los
trabajadores sólo pueden producir una
combinación de zapatos deportivos y
balones de básquetbol para ayudarnos a
comprender esto y entender que podemos
visualizar la información de diversas
maneras vamos a mostrarlo también como
una tabla de producción ya sea a partir
de las curvas de posibilidades de
producción o de una tabla de producción
podemos calcular el costo de oportunidad
de los zapatos y también de los balones
de básquetbol y luego deducir algunas
cosas acerca de la ventaja comparativa
entonces en la tabla de producción
ponemos el país y el país de lo que
queremos saber es cuál es el máximo de
valores que producen por trabajador por
día y cuál es el máximo de zapatos
también por trabajador por día vamos a
hacer una pequeña tabla para hacer el
cálculo pausa en el vídeo y traten de
llenar la tabla
entonces cuál es el máximo de balones de
básquetbol si el país a pone toda su
energía en balones de básquetbol se
encuentra en este punto de su curva de
posibilidades de producción entonces
puede producir ocho balones de
básquetbol ahora en el otro extremo de
la curva si pone toda su energía en
zapatos no producirá balones de
básquetbol pero si seis pares de zapatos
de manera similar si vamos al país ve y
preguntamos cuál es la cantidad máxima
de balones de básquetbol que produce si
pone toda su energía en ellos
obtendremos cuatro balones y ningún par
de zapatos y si pone toda su energía en
zapatos no producirá ningún balón pero
si cuatro pares de zapatos así de
sencillo esta tabla de producción nos
muestra los extremos de las curvas de
posibilidades de producción de estos
países con la información de la tabla de
producción y las curvas de posibilidades
de producción calculemos el costo de
oportunidad dibujemos otra tabla que va
a ser nuestra tabla de costo de
oportunidad ceo para los países a ive
vamos a calcular los costos de
oportunidad de producir balones de
básquetbol
de pares de zapatos y luego los costos
de oportunidad de producir pares de
zapatos en términos de balones de
básquetbol una vez más los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de llenar la
tabla de costos de oportunidad empecemos
con cuál es el costo de oportunidad de
producir balones en términos de zapatos
en el país
existen dos maneras de plantearnos esta
pregunta imaginemos un mundo donde el
país
no produce balones de básquetbol y
produce seis pares de zapatos si el
número de balones que produce aumenta a
ocho entonces va a dejar de producir
seis pares de zapatos por lo tanto en el
país a ocho balones de básquetbol
cuestan seis pares de zapatos otra
manera de plantearlo es si dividimos
estos dos entre ocho obtenemos que un
balón cuesta seis entre ocho pares de
zapatos que es lo mismo que tres cuartos
de un par de zapatos podemos indicarlo
como 0.75 z donde z significa un par de
zapatos de igual manera si el país ve
pasa de 0 a 4 balones de básquetbol
tendrá que dejar de producir 4 pares de
zapatos por lo
en el país ve cuatro balones de
básquetbol cuestan cuatro pares de
zapatos podemos dividir ambos lados
entre cuatro y obtenemos que un balón de
basquetbol cuesta un par de zapatos z es
otra vez un par de zapatos también
podríamos haber obtenido este resultado
haciendo una ecuación a partir de la
información que tenemos aquí si el país
pone toda su energía en balones de
básquetbol puede producir ocho balones
pero si pone la misma energía en zapatos
puede producir seis pares de zapatos
entonces con la misma energía puede
producir cualquiera de los dos si
queremos el costo de oportunidad de los
balones
dividimos ambos entre ocho eso es
básicamente lo que hicimos aquí y
obtenemos que un balón de basquetbol
cuesta seis octavos de un par de zapatos
o tres cuartos de un par de zapatos que
es exactamente lo que tenemos aquí ahora
calculemos el costo de oportunidad de un
par de zapatos en cada país existen dos
maneras de plantearnos esto podemos
verlo como el recíproco o podemos volver
a esta ecuación si el país pone toda su
energía en zapatos podría producir seis
pares pero sí
toda su energía en balones podría
producir ocho de ellos dividimos ambos
lados entre seis que son los pares de
zapatos y obtenemos que la energía
necesaria para producir un par de
zapatos es equivalente a la energía que
se necesita para producir ocho sextos de
un balón lo cual es igual a cuatro
tercios de un balón
si queremos convertirlo a decimales sólo
para simplificar o tal vez para hacer
más fácil la comparación vemos que esto
es aproximadamente 1.33 el costo de
oportunidad de producir un par de
zapatos en el país
es de aproximadamente 1.33 balones de
básquetbol para el país ve podemos hacer
una ecuación similar en este país con la
misma energía que se necesita para
producir cuatro pares de zapatos se
pueden producir cuatro balones de
básquetbol esto es básicamente lo que
hicimos aquí dividimos ambos lados entre
cuatro la energía necesaria para un par
de zapatos es igual a la energía
necesaria para un balón así que el costo
de oportunidad de producir un par de
zapatos es igual a un balón de
básquetbol ahora estamos listos para
establecer la conexión dados los costos
de oportuna
y calculamos qué país tiene la ventaja
comparativa en balones de básquetbol
pausa en el vídeo y traten de
averiguarlo examinemos el costo de
oportunidad de producir un balón de
básquetbol en cada país en el país a
cada balón le cuesta a un trabajador
tres cuartos de un par de zapatos
mientras que en el país ve le cuesta un
par de zapatos completo entonces en
realidad el país
tiene un costo de oportunidad más bajo
en la producción de balones de
básquetbol y por lo tanto tiene la
ventaja comparativa si examinamos los
zapatos es a la inversa el país tiene un
costo de oportunidad de uno y un tercio
de balones por par de zapatos mientras
que el país vez tiene un costo de
oportunidad de un balón por par de
zapatos por lo que tiene un costo de
oportunidad más bajo en realidad esto
puede resultar un poco contradictorio
porque si observan el eje de los zapatos
el país
tiene la ventaja absoluta en la
producción de zapatos en el país a cada
día un trabajador puede producir seis
pares de zapatos mientras que en el país
ve un trabajador sólo puede producir
cuatro pares de zapatos
pero aunque el país tenga la ventaja
absoluta en realidad lo que tendría
sentido sería que se enfocará en los
balones de básquetbol mientras que el
país ve se enfoca en los zapatos en el
siguiente vídeo veremos como ambos
países pueden comerciar entre sí para
alcanzar un escenario por encima de sus
curvas de posibilidades de producción y
porque tiene sentido enfocarse en la
ventaja comparativa al menos en este
mundo teórico y muy simplificado la
ventaja comparativa funciona nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo